esto fue lo poco que quedó de un lujoso
complejo hotelero en la costa sur de
españa después de ser devorado por las
llamas en estepona a las afueras de
málaga esta construcción un centro
comercial y decenas de casas tuvieron
que ser evacuados según los vecinos el
fuego se extendió rápidamente por esta
zona de andalucía impulsado por los
fuertes vientos casi cinco minutos
parecía como si una cantidad de viento
suave controlado con la ayuda de
helicópteros y aviones los bomberos
intentan controlar el fuego provocado
por las cada vez más altas temperaturas
de verano de acuerdo con el gobierno
español en los últimos 20 años se han
registrado en promedio 11 mil 500
incendios por año en el país y la
afectación de superficie forestal ha
sido de más de 90 mil hectáreas en
promedio el 2020 no es la excepción en
lo que va del año hasta el 23 de agosto
se han registrado casi 5 mil 600
siniestros aunque la afectación es una
tercera parte más baja de lo que fue en
el mismo lapso de 2019 otra de las
regiones en donde hay más incendios
activos es extremadura sobre todo en el
área conocida como valle del jerte con
incendios que comenzaron en la madrugada
del viernes y avanzan sin control